[Music]
you thought that it's all too easy for
us to fall into a sort of rut in our
thinking and it can feel so comfortable
so good you can feel so certain that
it's right that we can't even realize
that we're stuck in a rut part of this
is called einstellung
like this kind of effect and that is
this sort of you see one approach to do
things and you are convinced it's right
and even if it isn't the best approach
you just can't see other approaches
because you've already locked in that
first approach and to some extent we do
that in everything we do in life because
as we grow as we go from infants and
we'll maturing there are synoptic we're
going and kind of our earliest years we
have lots of synoptic connections and as
we don't use some of them they just
wither away and die so even by six
months of age what happens is you've
lost the ability to even hear certain
sounds of other languages because you
haven't actually used those those
circuits yourself so what you were to do
in your life is you want to try to
expose yourself to novel stimuli as much
as possible so I mean that doesn't mean
that you have to like live a topsy-turvy
life but try things like sitting at a
different place at the dinner table or
brush your teeth with the other hand and
of course travel is a great way of
getting out of your comfort zone one of
the things that I think is very
interesting is Nobel Prize winner
Lamoni cahal had said that he he's
considered the father of modern
neuroscience and he had worked with many
geniuses and he said you know I work
with these geniuses and he said I am
a genius he said what I am is persistent
and I'm flexible when I say when I see
that the data is telling me something
different than I thought it should tell
me so he was able to change his mind now
what happens with really smart people
those geniuses Hoover Monica Hall was
referring to is they're they're super
smart so they're used to being right
right and figuring things out quickly
they tend to jump to conclusions and
they haven't had the experience of
changing their minds when they're wrong
because they haven't been wrong yet
often and what that does is that makes
them less flexible in the face of
changing data or even being more open to
different ideas so I think it's it's
really important to try to keep yourself
flexible try to talk to people of
differing opinions listen to them of
course you'll be forming your own
opinions but you'll be surprised if you
listen carefully how you can find
yourself being a more open and caring
person just for the fact that you can
listened my background is a little
different in that I worked for several
years as a Russian translator on Soviet
trawlers so it was an eye-opening
experience for me because it allowed me
to realize how easy it is for people to
get in a an echo chamber where they they
have no idea that there are other
opinions and other ideas that are
outside their own echo chamber so I saw
that on the trawlers that I worked on
they there was no exposure to Western
ideas and Western thoughts and so they
they were convinced that all all
capitalists were evil that people would
when they got to shore they would be
kidnapped and tortured and terrible
things would happen to them and of
course that wasn't true at all and their
conceptions of the West
Wheatly wrong another thing was just
that they were terrified of saying the
wrong thing it was truly a totalitarian
society where if you had one think you
were in big trouble and to some extent I
see a little of that going on in our
society today people become very
polarized because they only listen to
news that relates to something that
backs up the worldview that they had and
so it's almost a little bit like that or
the old days when I was working with the
Soviets because there's this sort of
groupthink that we're right and and also
fear if you say the wrong thing amongst
your group and this is this is a
dangerous sort of societal situation to
fall into where you're not listening or
talking to one another and I think it's
important that as much as possible to
maintain dialogue between different ways
of thinking about things and as well as
far as false news comes and fake news
comes about I unfamiliar with fake news
from from decades past right because the
Soviets were masters of fake news and
fake news can come from any source and
it's not just your side that's the
source of the good news it's both sides
that can put out great news and so I
think critical thinking involves not
being totally vested in one side or
another but being able to step back and
be dispassionate
and not be quite so emotional about the
things you might hear in the news that
are built to push your emotional buttons
[Music]
you